so he said ah look it look it look it
look a lot good yeah yeah you wouldn't
you when you when you went
in and i was sorry yeah you're
struggling
um and she's like no no you open
pandora's box
yeah yeah i'm finna get busy
what's up team what's good fandom
partners producers
lovers haters haters welcome back
um i hope you're having a great day
um i hope the sun is blessing you my
birthday is one
week closer guys so uh you know what you
know that means
bro 30 for 30. 30 patrons on my 30th
birthday that's what we need
run it through bro that's all we need
something found through
i'll tell you what i'll sweeten the pot
i'll sweeten the pot okay
what are you saying if you man give me
us 30 for 30. yeah 30 patrons on my 30th
birthday
if we hit or exceed that number yeah
we'll throw in a special bonus episode
gang
yeah easy light 30 for 30 we'll spend
throw in a special bonus episode for you
man
if we get 30 patrons on my birthday
right so
22nd of april was the day keep it marked
they have to come in on that day on that
day
on that day they have to come in 30
pages on my 30th birthday let's go
i'm not playing anymore i'm bored of it
i'm bored of it
we can see it as well we'll know if we
get 30 or not we can
come through the analytics don't lie
they do not lie my g
but as usual guys like subscribe if this
is your first time with us welcome make
sure you hit that subscribe button guys
we're going for 800 likes on this video
please i beg of you if you can run us
800 likes i'm going to be so
gassed so gassed um it's doable
jump in the comments i want to be more
active in the comments guys so we're
going to start replying to you guys a
lot more yeah
in the comments um obviously the
messages we can keep it up to date with
you guys as much as we can follow us on
instagram twitter
um and obviously as you know sign up for
the patreon as per
um so this week guys the episode is
brought to you by
manscaped so the boys at manscaped and
the girls have created the best
ball hair trimmer ever it's called the
lawn mower 3.0
third generation trimmer which features
cutting edge
ceramic blade to reduce grooming
accidents
thanks to their advanced skin safe
technology it's crazy
you will never nick your balls again
brother ever that's a scary thing you
feel like you're going to bleed out
and it stings for ages things like a
paper cut fam
been there bro it would never happen
again so bro i feel confident
in addition this trimmer comes with an
edit above it comes with an led light
to get the nooks and crannies crazy
those nooks and crannies the gooch
the gooch it's pitch black down there
the gooch is pitch black so led sorted
um so it gives you a more precise shave
and
cream of the crop it's waterproof bruv
so keeps your um shower shave clean
and easy boom there you go man and get
20
off and free shipping as well with the
code sng
at manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com
please don't forget to use the smg code
unlock your confidence and
always use the right tools for the job
with manscape guys
enjoy enjoy that guys without further
ado let's jump into the show peoples
yeah man
um the fun fact of the day is actually
from something time ago about people
that used to go in a coma
so yeah due to medicine not being so
great back in the day
comatose people were sometimes
mistakenly buried alive
it's in order to counteract these
potential blunders
people were buried with little bells
above the ground these bells were
attached to a string which went into the
coffin if the person was buried alive
and later wake up they would tug on the
string that would ring a bell above
ground
someone would hear it and then dig the
person out their premature resting place
that is insane
bro they'll suffocate before they wake
up from a coma
insane that's ridic it was so that was
just such common thing
that we just they just thought but we're
gonna have to support bells on these man
these men keep waking up how did they
even know they woke up
i think i read a bit more into it and
it's it was either it was either one of
two things
um maybe i think a few times they had
dug up a grave and they saw like
scratches and stuff
or i think it was that i couldn't have
been banging because when you're six
finder you won't you won't hear [ __ ]
yeah i think it was that one i think
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah just scratching and that and i
think um
the people that did some some of the
people that it didn't bury obviously
when they woke up from a coma they
thought oh maybe because they've got
similar symptoms yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
they've clogged our big man we've buried
about 10 people with the same thing when
we woke up today
these men could have woken up yesterday
they started digging these man up
scratches all over the gap so then they
started before
we need the bell for these man this is
getting out of hand
i'm not waking up in a grave i'll tell
you that now
it's literally buried alive what's that
is that what the movie's called buried
buried
right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'll
smash my skull against the thing until i
die forever
i'm not but there's not much space you
just need there you're doing that for
time
there's vex there's not much space i'll
have to bite my tongue off like you said
fam i'm just thinking where's the bell
it must be around your neck or sitting
in it
well no no no sorry not where's the bell
because the bell's above ground where's
the string yeah i'm assuming it must be
tight around your neck
yeah but you're
if you wake up okay sonori let's say
you've you've actually gone into a coma
you've woken up in a coffin
underground uh six feet under rather and
obviously he's pitch black and you just
feel something around your neck you're
awake you don't know where you are but
you
you can engage you're in a coffin and
this is back a day as well so
this went this these fancy plush coffins
you're in a box you're literally in a
box you're in like a two by four
yeah yeah so it's just wood yeah and
wood
and you feel rope around your neck
you're not gonna start doing all of
these things because you're gonna assume
there's a [ __ ] bell up there
but it gets if it's common knowledge
if it's common knowledge that like guys
just so you know
we're putting bells around because like
for example if we walked around a
graveyard today yeah and just bag of
bells if it's just
in our upbringing that we know why
there's bells all over the grapes
if you wake up in a box you know there's
a belt
yeah yeah yeah obviously if they
introduce the bell system yeah
whilst you're in this coma it's long for
you
you'll freeze yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
but i'm assuming if you know there's
just bells gaff
like all over the gaf like you'd think
if you wake up
feel something around your neck clump
bell and you just
swing your phone oh ring it please
and say oh someone will hear it who fam
is a graveyard
who's hearing it imagine there's just
bag of bells
and there's just you there's like four
or five bells
dinging imagine imagine imagine imagine
imagine imagine so this is like a
scenario yeah let me hit me and maybe
this is like pretty much what you said
to me that one time with the graveyard
killer yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
say if you're just like an undertaker or
something yeah or you're just a
maintenance guy at graveyard yeah yeah
yeah
or you're just taking a stroll for a for
a graveyard yeah
it's a cold winter's night there's
there's fog
all over the thing yeah
and then you're walking through the
graveyard let's just say there's a
shortcut for you to get home which means
you have to walk through a graveyard
yeah
you walk for a graveyard and
all of a sudden fam you hear a bell next
to you
you're walking you hear dining you think
it's the wind you stop
and you're like hello hello
what the [ __ ] do you do am i an ordinary
person or who am i you're foo head
walking you don't know whose grave this
is oh i'm i'm gonna continue walking big
man
i tell you that for free for free you're
just gonna let donny suffocate down
there
what so i've got knowledge about this
belting if we live in the universe where
bells are a thing
okay you're walking past grace and
there's bells dyed all over the place
and you're walking past one of them oh
no i'm gonna say you live in oliver
twist days you just got the cap
and your britches and you're just
walking fam and just
there's no one the [ __ ] around it's the
middle of the night
there's no houses nearby you live like a
mile away from here
you haven't got a phone you can't ring
someone i thought i was going to say i
was going to ring someone yeah
you said oliver twist there's a thing up
there's nowhere you've got nothing
there's just a bell ringing fam and you
got your claws and your know-how
what the [ __ ] are you doing are you
running off because if you run off
it's never going to come back to you no
one will
ever find out but me my question but you
my country you'll know
if i'm actually being practical about it
i'd still have to probably run away
purely because no purely because there
is no like you said all i've got is my
my hands and my know-how i can't do
anything
i literally can't do anything about that
i can dig the
soft dirt enough he's six foot
underground big man
that's taller than me do you know what i
mean
like i can't i can't do that with my
hands i can't do that with my hands i'm
sorry
i'm a i'm a young kid you know what i
mean yeah yeah oliver twist times i'm
not i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry he's just gonna have to keep
dinging away
there's nothing i can do there's nothing
i can do
[ __ ] there's literally nothing i can do
because how am i meant to [ __ ] like come
on bro come on
digging up a grave with your hands
nowadays these men are using actual
machinery to dig up graves
it's long for him or her it's long
it's long it will eat my conscious alive
yeah
or actually i live what a mile away yeah
that's that's a 10 minute walk
a mile away yeah you'll probably get
home in like 10 minutes a dart home
i dart home and call someone not call
someone but like in and around my area
i've been like
guys there's a bell it's ding-a-ling
it's ding-a-ling and we have to do
something about it but on my lonesome
night
i'd just keep going home cool so
you get home you scream guys there's a
ding-a-ling
ding-a-ling-a-ling yeah and then the
townspeople congregate together we all
dip over there
it takes us 10 minutes to get over there
we get there just as someone's running
to the grave
the last thing stops and it's it's
getting fainter and fainter
and as soon as you get there it's
[Music]
everyone turns to you and it's like
ah first of all they're like ah [ __ ]
thought i'm sorry bro we missed it we
missed it but thank you
for coming like thank you for coming to
to warn us like we did our best and
you're like [ __ ]
and you're just about to turn around and
one [ __ ]
turns around and it's like wait
if you had no offense but
the earth is untouched and you're like
yeah
and then he doesn't like you here you go
man's like did you try and help him
or did you just run off and get someone
else what are you saying
the whole town's watching you now did
you try and help him
or did you just [ __ ] off and get someone
else to do it
are you gonna say what did you want me
to do that's basically what i'm gonna
say
what do you want from me because i can't
lie because you've just said the earth
is untouched
i can't lie about it i can't say oh yeah
i tried to do it i couldn't do it so i
put the [ __ ] back
and then run over yeah so i'm gonna have
to tell the truth bee
i'd have to take i have to take what
comes i'd have to take what comes
fair play because i can't lie about that
fair play
fair play it's the evidence is there or
literally not there you know
fair play fair play fair play fair play
i mean facts
what would you do faulting
holding initial belts initial belting
you're walking through
jimmy as you are yeah knowing me i know
exactly what i would do
i'll be a [ __ ] psychopath
as soon as i hear the bell instinct i'm
running i'm looking at you
instinct gone middle of the night fog
gone gone gone
i'll probably make it to the end of the
little hallway wherever it is yeah
little
street yeah um isle whatever i'll make
it down
and i'm like [ __ ] i'd rather i know what
it is now i know what that is
i'd sprint back as fast as i could i'd
probably get like
yeah two scoops and real and then
realize like
i can't [ __ ] i'm never gonna get down in
time and then i'd probably
run five more steps and think i've
wasted time here
yeah i can't make that in time come back
one more scoop i'm definitely not going
to make it
come back i'll be doing that the whole
half an hour
and then i've been i would have been
running up and down the street
indecisive
the whole time and then the dings would
have stopped and i would have thought to
myself
if i would have just left in the [ __ ]
first place i would have he probably
would be alive
or if i'd actually just stayed and kept
digging he'd probably be alive
but my indecisiveness killed someone
damn and then i'd lie about it and i
tell everyone that i heard the ding
i scooped two and then it stopped
hanging that's probably what i'd
say and i'd live a hero
probably ah everyone give me props for
trying my best
but the truth is not that the truth is a
panicked
oh my days that's jokes if you want the
honest truth from that's probably what
it is
damn i would dart and scoop and scoop
and dart
okay scenario imagine imagine you're the
one in the
in the coffin and you're the one dinging
the ting
but you hear someone you can hear the
footsteps now
yeah and you ding ding ding ding ding
you hear the footsteps running towards
you so you like okay someone's someone's
heard me and someone's about to save me
yeah yeah
you can hear them scoop they dart off
again so you can hear the [ __ ]
footsteps running away
yeah yeah yeah you've not heard anything
for time so you're dang however because
obviously you're gonna be like this so
however you're digging the belt just
shaking however you're digging about
you're [ __ ] swinging your neck side
to side
like a [ __ ] yeah absolutely yeah
yeah swinging side to side side side
side
and you're thinking okay [ __ ] i need to
stop i need to conserve my energy
because i will die in here yeah if i
don't you know yeah yeah you leave it
roughly to what your imagination would
be five minutes because you don't know
what five minutes would be like
um you leave it for five minutes and you
go again nothing nothing nothing
and you think oh my god like
what what am i actually gonna do what am
i actually going to do
and then and then you're digging um
sorry you do your last little ding
and you hear like a scurry of footsteps
so obviously you've assumed that
they're coming trying to save you now so
the person that was there before has
gone to like um
my scenario going to get people come
back
but the um okay no no
no no no no no no no no no no
we started it fresh we're starting it
fresh and then we're gonna because
all right starting a fresh sorry guys
we're starting fresh because i've got a
fresh
new idea in my head right go so same
things happened
yeah you're in the coffin right yeah the
noose is around your neck yeah and the
bells are float yeah yeah
so you've woken up now you're twisting
your neck dinging dinging
dinging dinging digging boom right
you've heard someone just scurry
yeah go on you've heard someone just
scurry nothing else
all you've heard is a scurry and that
instinctively makes you panic and ding
more so you're like ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
cool you hear nothing for about two
minutes you think okay [ __ ] maybe
they've maybe they've just gone
yeah maybe they've just gone yeah let's
say i'm that person that
that's heard the ding right yeah you're
in the coffin i've heard the ding
bet cool we're all here now
i come back yeah but meanwhile you've i
come back with like the townsfolk right
yeah
i live a mile away like yeah yeah yeah
um
but the graveyard is [ __ ] massive
oh dear the cemetery not graveyard so
the cemetery is massive yeah it sounds
humongous yeah yeah so you're like okay
you're trying to
figure out where abouts you've heard the
sound because you can't remember now
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so you
think you think it's there you think is
that but all of a sudden
you're dinging again because you you can
not hear anything i get a sense
but you could kind of sense things like
that let me try again yeah you just got
that sudden urge like okay
you've got the sixth sense i'm just
going to try and dig in because i feel
like some mix
this time someone's going to hear me you
you swing your neck
with everything like dang dang dang dang
yeah we're digging galore fam
okay and me as few had i'm hearing it
now i'm thinking
oh my god guys it's over there it's over
there let's go let's go let's go let's
go let's go
but you're obviously this this has
probably been about so it's 10 minutes
there
10 minutes back the initial thing this
has probably been about half an hour now
half an hour in a coffin limited oxygen
limited strength
you've woken up from a coma your day's
as [ __ ] you don't know why go on yeah
yeah all of a sudden
like me and the townsfolk digging
digging digging we could we can
we've got to the parameter of where the
noise was coming from we're digging
digging digging
and you can hear us it's that close that
you can hear
us yeah yeah you can [ __ ] hear us
yeah yeah yeah yeah but you've not got
the strength
i can't do it i can't you've let out
another thing just there
hoping praying and wishing for just a
[ __ ] door not yeah
yes please you made it and then you
realize they've opened the one next to
you so yeah i hear that
open my eyes it's still pitch black
just dust in my face they've opened the
one next to you bro
that's the reason why you could hear it
ah
i knew you were gonna say that the whole
time it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
is he alive too oh they just opened a
corpse
they have a bit of corpse big man
they've opened up corpse so now they
need they don't know where you are they
just know you're in this surrounding
area because this is where they've heard
the sound
but you've you've lost it all bro you're
just
like you've literally taken your last
breath uh
but you you might have the strength to
move but it's like this
but it's not causing enough yeah it just
sounds like it's
nick sounds like wind it's not knocking
the bell at all oh brav
so i just have to suffer inside i have
to suffer in silence bro
[Music]
please i would have given up by then as
soon as i heard that
and then they're not open mind i would
give up
uh
salvation
you pricks that is jokes anyways
that's cool man um what you got for me
today okay
would you rather let your parents watch
a porno of you
or watch a porno with your parents
how long is the porno from both sides
five minutes
it's a five minute scene and i have to
watch the whole five minutes it's from
beginning to end yeah
who am i in a porno with just a porn
star
um i would probably pick
ah stuff because i'm thinking about like
the ramifications
yeah it's always about the trauma i
would probably pick
i'm gonna have to say watch my parents
you'd rather watch your parents than
your parents watch you
um why so i think because
actually no no no no i changed my mind
i changed my mind completely they'd have
to watch me
they'd have to watch me yeah yeah you're
not watching yeah i can't watch them
i i can't i couldn't even justify why i
chose them yeah you know what i mean
yeah i couldn't even justify like they'd
have to watch me because i can't watch
them
that's the only justification they can
watch me i don't i literally i care
obviously
but in that scenario i don't care they'd
have to watch me
watch me watch me the only thing is i
don't know if they have do i have to i'm
wondering if i have to watch them watch
me
because that's different that's very
different
do i have to be there while they watch
me
because that would be traumatizing it
changes everything it does
it actually does okay so would you
rather
watch them watch you or
would you rather be there while they
have sex for five minutes
so your parents having sex for five
minutes so you have to see that live
yeah
or you've filmed a porno and you're
parents with my parents you have to
basically watch five minutes of it with
your parents
not like the intro but like deep into it
yeah or watch your parents
have sex live for five minutes um
[Music]
i think i actually think i'd still go
with they can watch me
and i would have to it would be the most
awkward five minutes of my life the five
minutes would last like a year
yeah yeah yeah but i'm not what i'm not
watching my parents do nothing
i'm not watching nothing especially from
there
i could smell the must don't nah
don't don't hear the pants don't don't
don't don't disgusting don't
disgusting don't i'm not here for that
at all
that's disgusting do you not think that
that's probably how like let's say for
example um
my sister or if
you had like an older banging sister for
example
you would never look at your sister that
way but there's mandem that obviously
look at your sister that way yeah yeah
yeah and it's just obviously the same
thing with the parents like you would
never want to see that as much as um the
rents might
love obviously having sex with
themselves you know but they obviously
wouldn't want the kid to to have to have
a look
but when when they're in sometimes when
you're in the moment you just don't care
like i know i've had sex sometimes where
if someone kind of walked in right now
you're just gonna carry on dude
sometimes you just don't care and it's
even better when she doesn't care
when she doesn't care fam
fam when she doesn't care i'm like okay
i'm in for a different thing here this
is a different evening but yeah that's
that's what i'm saying like when
um if you had like an older sister for
example and it was like
everyone wanted a banger kind of thing
no offense um
yeah i just had to get that out of there
it's just kind of weird because
obviously you're gonna see her as
completely different here yeah that's
disgusting she's my sister yeah
i'm never going to be attracted to that
yeah you can understand
yeah that's the thing you underst you
also understand that
when people are like because it is uh
but at the same time you know what good
looking looks like
regardless if it's your sister your mom
wherever you know what good looking
looks like
so just understand yeah just firm it
it's grim
just firm just firm it um
quick one completely off off topic i
just need to get this on my chest i've
been watching too much of the office you
know when we talk about the office
before
yeah yeah i've been watching too much of
the office i love the show too much to
the point
what i think subconsciously i think i'm
in the office
james happened to me yesterday
yesterday i was gonna say today
yesterday i was in the petrol station
this has happened so picture this i'm in
the petrol station
so i'm facing here in the queue there's
a guy in front of me paying for his
petrol
mm-hmm so she's like let's just say that
i'm here
in the queue holding like my kind of
monster that i'm about to buy or
whatever
just sitting there the guy in front of
me is about to pay and she's like okay
cool that'll be 64.80
and he's like cool and he goes to tap it
and she goes
no you need to put it in and i was like
that's what she said
but not only did i say that's what she
said i looked at the roof
i looked at the roof there's a camera
doesn't she like that's what
i said today oh no you need to put it in
that's what she said
bro i snapped out of it and i was like
i'm not even what am i doing i'm by
myself bro
there's no camera it was so
weird but it felt so good
it does when you have that in the
monologue bro it feels amazing
it felt so good i was like man i wish i
was in the office
such a great show where's my camera but
then again it also
falls back to the fan theory that we had
about rick and morty
about the parallel universes and the um
interdimensional television
so imagine you are on a show oh bro if
interdimensional tv is real
they had a whale of a time yesterday
they
thought oh he smashed it he smashed it
that's what she said that's what she
said
i see you see this it's jokes
i need to snap out of that that's jokes
where you up to um
season eight or nine so
andy's boss now uh
the last episode i watched was
where the last episode was watching
kevin was coming up with that weird
language
where he kept missing words out what is
that kevin do now
okay oh that isn't that the episode
where angela brings their baby to work
i haven't watched the whole episode yet
i think i've watched only the first bit
it might be
i think that's the i think that's
episode she does that i didn't even what
her baby she's had a baby
yeah if you're on season nine she's had
a baby fun i don't think i've not
is it an event when she has a baby no no
no no no no so she just brings it in
or maybe it is that i don't know if a
season nine or not because i never watch
what season i'm on
oh yeah i'll just keep watching it yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah um so me yeah i
don't know
okay well pam who has the baby first pam
or her
pam's more pregnant than her so surely
pam is the baby first night
because pam's pregnant right now oh
pam's pregnant man's pregnant right now
and pam looks fat this time did she get
pregnant for real i think she 100
percent got pregnant for real cool
because she's big yeah she got pregnant
for real that's the first thing i
thought
um then maybe maybe you're on season
eight okay probably season a yeah but
yeah kevin's coming up with some weird
language i can't remember what happened
uh again like you said i was just i was
binging it bro i was watching it back to
you yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we're just
smashing it through that's why i'm
dealing with parks and rec now
oh yeah i was going to watch parks and
rec and maybe superstore i don't know if
i'm going to watch superstar or not
told me about that yeah maybe we'll see
um where are you from one's gotta go
one's gotta go
guys um as you already know last week i
started a new segment called one's gotta
go
basically um i have a subtopic
and we have five categories no we've got
a topic
with um five different options
and jimmy has to pick one that's got a
goal really and there we go we go again
so today one is about
people and music yeah people and music
yeah all right cool
so one's gotta go guys um
i'm gonna show you the list if you can
see
boom i think you'll find this one very
interesting especially
as you move on from the first one i
think you really really like it
i'm excited bro i loved last one good i
loved it gang all right one's gonna go
people in music
so you've got drake kendrick lamar
j cole kanye west
this is a this is in the sense of
you know what all their music's like if
this this that if they
go you can never listen to their music
again okay
drake kanye west
ketchup lamar yeah i think
who actually don't know who you would
pick yeah because i don't know who i'm
gonna pick
i'm just gonna go on a whim and i think
that i know the reason why i'm going to
pick that one
i don't know if you can see that guys uh
yeah i'm gonna i think
uh i'm really torn
so drake kendrick lamar j cole kanye
i'm gonna get a lot of stick for this i
think that's who's gonna pick
i'm gonna get rid of even though i can
never listen to it again do i know it
existed
yeah you know it existed but you can't
listen to any you can't listen to any of
the old albums or anything new again
kanye that's what i picked for you cool
i knew you picked people are going to go
mad at me i knew you'd pick him purely
because
i kind of sensed that you wouldn't you
don't really listen to his stuff anymore
anyway
i haven't just done stuff in years and i
went back a few months ago
and listened to some old [ __ ] and i love
it still but it's
like graduation that's why that's why i
asked do i still know it existed
because i like to think for me his old
music is more representative
representative of a time in my life when
i was listening to it and how i felt
while i said yeah
it's not necessarily the music itself
but i do like hearing it again yeah i
listened to um
what randomly came on the other day
monster
came on the other day what a tune that's
an album bro
my beautiful doctors of fantasy is an
album album album
2010 bro album
album jesus mad that's an album everyone
dropped a
nasty verse on that song [ __ ] what's
their fave nicki minaj's verse
was crazy bro was crazy bro because
that's what a [ __ ]
oh she went off she went off but yeah
kanye's gotta go
i'll just have to remember his stuff
with like
delight as i am now but i don't need to
listen to it again fair enough all right
um but kendrick was on the chopping
block as well
but i'm waiting for him to drop sat in
nasty yeah because that dropped in since
17 2017 yeah he doesn't drop something
in a minute so i'm just on the cusp of
thinking he's gonna drop something
filthy
soon and he's gonna bang i'm just hoping
otherwise it would have been him but i
listened to section eight the other day
and i was like he's
he's the true stuff he's different um
all right next one yeah
denzel washington um samuel jackson i
knew he's going to be there as well will
smith
k morgan freeman oh
your face for each one i said sweet in
me
denzel okay seminar jackson you're going
to say that will smith oh
morgan freeman okay sweetie me
sweeten me um i think you're gonna go
for
this one guys i think he's gonna go for
that one okay i'm actually
going to say on this one morgan freeman
that's who i picked
yeah gang gang why um
because he's more of a symbol than he is
an actual
influential actor makes sense you know
what i mean makes perfect sense
if you think of his roles yeah like
he's not you he apart from his voice he
can be replaced
in pretty much any one of his iconic
roles to me apart from his voice
like he's he doesn't yeah i know what
you mean i don't really think he's ever
done anything where only morgan freeman
could
do could have done that performance just
spit yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you mean i know he's just a symbol for
me cool cool
all right i'm gonna read this one in a
different order
just so you don't know who i'm going to
choose that yeah yeah
yeah so you've got eddie murphy
martin lawrence k dave chappelle
yeah kevin hart oh it's obviously comedy
comedy yeah yeah yeah yeah i think
in all honesty your
he's going to pick this one
don't forget don't know if you can see
that guys but he's going to pick that
one
boom martin lawrence that's my pick
mine lawrence yeah yeah i think that was
easy for you purely because i know who
you're not going to pick
and i think like the other two you think
are funnier and you probably didn't
transcend with
martin lawrence as much as the other two
yeah me and i have never had a moment
have you ever seen like these old movies
like blue streaks blue streak and stuff
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah hilarious bro funny
oh yeah funny don't get me wrong funny
but um
i i've only recently in the last couple
of years really
started to dive into eddie murphy's
um like life story and stuff i listened
to a podcast literally last week
okay with eddie murphy and he was
talking about how he's come up and
everything like that yeah he started
stand up when he was 16.
wow and like yeah he's done
some [ __ ] bro and he's made music
my music party all the time
party all the time i think that was my
first fun fact
yeah one was it was one of the first
ones yeah and um
what was i gonna say eddie murphy
when you actually think about it his
performance
is in the um united professor
is unbelievably impeccable it's actually
like oscar where this is
crazy and i found out as well he had to
audition for every character he played
because they didn't want him to be
playing all these characters he had to
audition
and he proved to them that he would do a
better job than any actor they can get
for every single person in that family
no he was only supposed to be the night
professor he was not supposed to be
everyone else
he auditioned for every single person
bravo bravo he's a comedy genius
bravo yeah bro he's a serious guy
serious guy wow
wow that's for you for thought not for
you for thought about something i didn't
know um
i like this next one cool again i'm
gonna say in a completely different one
and i don't even know who i think you'd
pick but i'm gonna have to hazard a
guess
so we've got will ferrell
again this is kind of this is comedy
actors yeah will ferrell
ben stiller okay adam sandler
yeah jack black oh
i think based off
your like your actions
i think you're gonna it's out of two
okay
and i think you're gonna go for this one
i think he's going to go for that one
will ferrell bern stiller
adam sandler or jack black yeah i'm
going to get rid of
even though especially as of lakes i've
learned a little bit more about him
i respect him incredibly but i'm
actually going to pick adam sana
that's why cool okay i know eugene gang
he can hoop as well by the way did you
know i've heard yeah i've heard i've
heard i've heard of her i think i've
seen it on a few
like youtube visits yeah yeah yeah
i'm gonna get rid of him because
one he'll do anything for the bag which
i'm disappointed in
in his life yeah he's made some
atrocious movies
[ __ ] unbelievably bad yeah
like [ __ ] jack and jill i've not seen
that he plays himself and like a
his twin sister i've never seen it but
trash oh you know it's trash
he played um there's one we've got like
a secret like a magic remote controller
science
yes yes yes yes i can't remember where
it's called but yes he makes
garbage yes yes yes garbage um
but um he is a serious guy
and uncut gems was that i thought james
was a great
[ __ ] movie girls baby
the girls baby different
that was different cheeks were schlobber
double
oh my god bro you guys haven't seen
uncut germs on there uncle james is
decent he did a really good job in a
beautiful movie
and amazon is really actually really
good but yeah out of that lineup
um it was probably between him and
adam's um ben stiller i knew you're
gonna be but ben stiller like
writes pretty much all of his own [ __ ]
okay i didn't know that so all the
loads of the movies he said he wrote
okay and they're great
and some of the movies like zoolander
and i knew you're going to say that
zoolander how are you going to say that
unbelievable what a crazy concept to
make
a [ __ ] sick movie out of i know
you're gonna see it i love zoolander but
yeah okay cool what's up
cool uh this one i literally have no
idea who you're gonna pick
okay so i think this is this is probably
the hardest one
out of the five okay because it's you
okay
um so one's got to go this is music now
miguel
okay brent anderson pack
bruno mars wow i literally i'm not even
going to guess because i literally don't
have
a clue who you pick but if that's a lie
i'm good i guess because i have to
um and i think
it's out of two hmm this is hard
i'm shooting myself in the foot and i'm
angry at myself i've chosen him
because even i wouldn't know who to
choose but
i think he's going to use that but
anyway i'm going to choose
surprisingly to myself on this one i'm
going to choose miguel
it was out i was so annoyed i didn't
choose him i chose bruno mars for you
yeah i can see why you would choose he'd
probably yeah he was out of my girl or
bruno mars
for me for you rather you know but yeah
why me girl
um basically because i think
every album he's produced
pretty much from his first ever album
every album he's ever
produced after that i like less and less
songs
okay to the point where i feel like the
next album he does i might like
one song so it's just been like
i put him on such a pedestal and he's
lingering in my mind as someone who
who i used to love if i was introduced
to his music today
yeah he's a completely different person
yeah he's a different and that's not his
fault he's
he's doing his thing yeah yeah he's on
his own artistic journey
but he's grown apart from what i like
yeah yeah so that's that's who are
exactly the same person exactly the same
like kind of storyline for
the weekend for me same for the weekend
as well exact same for the weekend this
weekend was great back in the day i miss
his
really mommy kind of yeah the trilogy
stuff was everything house of balloons
all of that was everything like the
really heavily
drug influenced music it felt like he
was coming from um
i don't even know what's like a good
comparison like um
like a classic rock band i know what you
mean i know what you're like the rolling
stones or something he's just on heroin
all the time
and he's talking about cocaine and [ __ ]
he was a
different guy he was a different guy you
could tell he was broken yeah
broken his music was so sick and at the
time was completely different
to anything that was out especially from
a black guy
completely different yeah and now he's
just i don't even know what he's doing
now
he's [ __ ] do you see the thing he's
doing this thing now
yeah i don't know what he's about now
anyway one's got to go
drake kendrick lamar jacob
drake kendrick lamar yeah kendrick yeah
because he explained that earlier let me
just go into detail denzel washington
samuel jackson will smith so same thing
as the one before
you can never watch any of their movies
again and you can't watch anything new
of theirs again and i think i know who
you pick
let me show them before you okay i think
you'll pick him up
samuel jackson will smith denzel
washington
um frustrating enough i'm actually gonna
go with samuel
no way yeah i picked will smith yeah he
was about to go
okay but samuel i picked
because only because of what
will smith has brought out of me
emotionally in his performances okay i
think as a resume
samuel jackson smashes will smith okay a
few performances
samuel jackson's never brought anything
out of me i just think he's a great
addition to a movie
and i think he's a good enough draw for
me to watch a movie
okay that makes sense but if we're
talking about like
movies in a cinema one starring samuel
jackson and one star will smith
if someone said mate this is you've got
one ticket each you have to pick
maybe not in this day maybe not today
but give it
between five and ten years ago in a drop
of a hat would have gone will smith yeah
10 years ago oh around about that
pursuit happened as i am legend time
yeah in that kind of stick in his career
yeah you i would have done i would have
admit ten times out of ten i would have
chosen wilson if i ever say hi jackson
yeah
in terms of like here's a movie i can't
see anything about samuel jackson's the
star
here's me if i can't tell you anything
about will smith's star in that period
of time i would have gone back and will
smith easily
because i know it's going to bang yeah i
know it's going to be yeah at the minute
you got like your gemini man and
emptying there i haven't seen it either
it's just like he's missing a little bit
now but samuel jackson also the thing
with samuel jackson as well
is i don't feel like he has he probably
does but he
pretty much plays the same character
every film
you think to a degree to a degree
he really plays this
especially in the last like decade this
grumpy brooding
older black male okay i haven't seen him
happy
in about 15 years
[Laughter]
happy you know okay he plays the like so
if you think about like um
what's he in so he's in if you think
about him in django
mm-hmm just thing yeah yeah yeah
you also take him in um so every quentin
tarantino movie he plays the same guy
oh yeah similar character similar
character every queen entertainer movie
then he'll drop a movie that's not even
a good movie
so he'll play the villain in like um
what's that movie that uh the english
movie
he plays the villain in um what's this
like a secret agent it's like
uh like a secret agent a kingsman
okay he plays like the main villain in
that i've seen
him but i remember yeah he's a bit
cheesy and [ __ ] okay um but i think he's
a great actor
he's he's he's got some unbelievable
performances uh he's in a film called
the negotiator i've saw
fam the negotiator is incredible
i saw it for the first time about a
month and a half ago really i watched it
when i was a kid we just have a dvd as a
kid
classic he's in another [ __ ] movie
actually now i'm
potentially second guessing myself he's
in another [ __ ] movie called
is it called unspeakable unthinkable
unthinkable
i saw that straight up i've seen it
twice yeah but i saw unthinkable
straight after i watched negotiate
again wow incredible movie wow
incredible movie
wow incredible movie but the only reason
i chose will smith
is because even in all of those
incredible movies
it's not samuel jackson that makes the
movie incredible
it's an incredible movie and the
negotiators got kevin spacey kevin
spacey is just as [ __ ] impactful
as true jacksonville very true there's
no movie with samuel jackson in it that
i've ever thought
man if samuel jackson was not in this
movie it would be a [ __ ] [ __ ] movie
it would take a hit granted but
you put will anyone will smooth in
pursuit of happiness
and he ain't making me cry cuz
he [ __ ] smashed seven pounds as well
bro yeah
i am legend i nearly cried in all three
of those movies
there's a big boy movie three of them i
needed movies yeah
no one's ever made me cry he's got me
close three [ __ ] times
damn so will smith has to hold it down
okay four [ __ ] times because that
same was that [ __ ] fresh print scene
whether why don't he want me man he
nearly made me cry on that as well yeah
yeah so fast four times listening made
me cry all right
cool i love samuel jackson i don't want
that to be diminished all right but
but i'm getting deep into this one good
i knew this one would be a good one
all right next one dave already know
you're gonna pick
so one's gotta go dave chappelle kevin
hart eddie murphy
he's got i think he's gonna pick that
one oh okay let me think
just based off well to be fair just
based on what we've spoken eddie murphy
okay kevin hart given up because of what
you just said about eddie murphy before
yeah
um i just kevin hart is
like a different
breed of guy
a different breed of guy he's one of
those guys that's just like
you physically can't say anything
he's he can do it all and he's done it
all and he's probably the
most successful comedian of all time
he is the most successful comedian ever
no one is more successful than kevin
hart yeah he's gone clear
there's not a single man who's ever
lived who's a more successful comedian
than kevin hart
he's gone clear so there's no like eddie
murphy is awesome
his time he was considered and he's
still going hot
and even though he pumps a movie out
every year
they're all kind of good good movies
yeah
so i have to rate it man and his
every comedy special he's ever done is
been very [ __ ] decent
even the one he did in his yard that was
actually good
he wasn't his best it wasn't even his
top three it definitely wasn't
because i i didn't barely laugh once in
that nah i didn't
laugh don't get me wrong i didn't like
oh my god this is hilarious yeah yeah
yeah
yeah i didn't barely laugh but there was
i'd laughed
i left a good amount but kevin is just a
different he's a different breed of man
he's built two different um keep talking
i've thought of another one but i just i
needed to add it to my actual other list
okay i'll just throw up another but you
you'll definitely like this one for next
time but continue sorry all right
um i've got the next one okay so you're
gonna go
jack black will ferrell or ben stiller
one's gotta go
i think you will pick i already know
you're not gonna pick
um i think he's going to pick
i don't even know if you can see it guys
i'm so sorry but yeah uh i'm picking ben
stiller yeah that's what happened
cool easy yeah easy um
brent anderson pack bruno mars
bruno mars unfortunately but i think my
man's a genius i know
so do i but it's just unfortunate it's
up against the other two yeah it's
unfortunate
yeah i don't know who you're not going
to pick so yeah exactly
all right drake j cole one's gotta go
jacob's coming
jacob's gone gone i don't even have to
think
about that drake's the the greatest
artist who ever lived
he's too great um denzel washington
will smith once cargo denzel washington
or will smith
will's gotta go yesterday denzel's a
different kind of guy i watched um
i watched american gangster again
another time for the
second or second or third time the other
day i think it was last week
i was about a month ago month or two ago
great movie great movies in that movie
great movie they have that's just elba's
in that movie
cast bro samuel jackson's uh
jackson um desert washington um denzel
washington's brother who plays the guy
from taurez if
he's a slave i can't remember his name
british guy
oh sit wait what's it again the guy the
main guy
was the actual brother in the movie
the guy that's in um scandals in it um
i can't write something pope i can't
breathe that the i don't know
who's the guy the first guy that died um
his like protege kind of thing no he's
like brother he was a protestant the
older guy oh the older guy
him so you know he had a friend the guy
with the like the black guy with the
moustache oh the older guy the church
the like
uh pasta ish looking guy he's in it he's
a famous actor yeah he is
yeah russell crowe is the the [ __ ]
second lead yeah oh my god yeah bro
russell crowe
um and who else was there people in that
movie
various people in that movie people in
that movie yeah great movie
um so yeah denzel ain't going nowhere
cool um the last one
so you said where am i so denzel won
so and then next one all right no you're
gonna pick um
we'll throw a jack back no that's the
one
is the greatest community of all time i
know i know so kevin hart's going i
already knew that
um i already know he's going in this one
warfare or jack black
paul for i was going i knew that already
because i circled that i love jack black
this one is hard because i know you love
anderson pack but i know you love brent
brent anderson pack bro
that's tricky
i will go with brynn's got a guy
damn but i know you love anderson paxo
ow i think i
don't know but i just think i have a
feeling
anderson pack from what i've heard
anderson pranks more musically talented
than bran
anderson pack is talented he can play
almost any instrument he can play
literally every instrument he can
kind of sing he can rap he can do
everything you know he can literally do
everything
everything so brent hasn't got the range
that anderson has yeah
but brent can sing oh he can sang
he's bringing toxic back
he actually is he's talking about lyrics
yeah he's so toxic
he's disgustingly toxic and his host
love it
it's been a minute since we had one of
those we need to hold on to him
we need to champion him thank you but
they ain't you you love to put that [ __ ]
up your nose
bro still love you and i still love you
bro be doing [ __ ] that nobody knows
in the streets there's gonna be thinking
you lady you're my [ __ ]
porn star i swear to god i swear to god
yeah brav if you ain't nasty don't at me
at me if you ain't nasty
don't at me oh
i've been working all day fam
i like to roam the streets until it's
dark out then come home
back out i hope that's okay i hope so
bringing toxic back i can't leave you
alone bro i can't leave you alone he is
actually bringing toxic back yeah yeah
and he's sick guys i'm glad you like
that one dude yeah cigarette that was
that was fun bro
um so we've got uh a uh am i the [ __ ]
to finish
user have you got one for me you've got
a sword
yep i've got one sword right
so i know you've actually seen this one
already what because i did i reply
uh or did i reply yes you did reply okay
bet
cool i'll probably just reply my normal
stuff though but yeah no you've read
this one oh
yeah okay right so hey guys i need to
know if i'm the [ __ ]
yeah my husband and i decided to open
our marriage recently
he has pressured me about threesomes for
years
and i wasn't interested i asked if we
could start looking for some friends
with benefits though
because i love sex all the time and my
husband only wants it once a month
i was having a lot of luck finding
people shock and my husband only had a
couple girls he was only halfway
interested in
shock when i started making plans to
meet one of the guys
i was talking to my husband changed his
mind and says he can't
share me shock yeah i realized that
sweet of him
not really possessive to want me to
himself but he
never really cared before there was a
real opportunity
opportunity for me to get laid and he
wasn't having much success
shark i know he's got some real emotions
about this
it's really upsetting him and i don't
want to hurt him still
i want to be happy too and i haven't
been most of our marriage
i still love him and he's my best friend
but i'm pretty
invested in living this lifestyle we've
basically been roommates for the last 10
years
and now he's ready to be a doting
husband and i'm kind of over it
i dealt with him treating me like crap
for years i just want to be selfish for
a bit
he's literally crying every day and
buying me [ __ ] all the time
and he's sweet but i never asked for
gifts and i need a minute away from him
and he won't leave me be
am i the [ __ ] for wanting to live my
life this way even though it's hurting
him
right for me that
changed as it went through
like it went from
so it went from am i the [ __ ] because
my my husband wanted to have an open
relationship
i didn't want to have an
entrepreneurship but i'm cool to sort
out some friends with benefits yeah
which is basically an open relationship
yeah
he then wasn't having he couldn't get
any [ __ ]
and she was getting dicks thrown out
thrown at her so he was like
hold up wait wait a minute let me let
you put some two sets into this software
because i'm i'm not this
ain't working the way i had it this
isn't the way the dreams were meant to
go
it's not computing so he said ah look it
look it look it looked like
pandora's box yeah yeah i'm finna get
busy
and he said stop and now he's getting
upset like that please stop stop stop
stop
please stop stop stop stop stop no
seriously stop please i was joking
so now she's
talking about uh it's gone from i want
sex all the time and he doesn't want it
that much
and this is a good outlet for me to
benefit our relationship
to he's treated me like [ __ ] for years
we've been nothing but roommates
it's kind of the way it was painted was
kind of like we're in a happy
relationship but our sex life could do
some work
here's a resolution i want it he doesn't
to he's treating me like a piece of [ __ ]
i'm fed up with it i want some time away
it's just like at the end of it it felt
like what's the sex god do it now
where's the sex [ __ ] because i thought
it was about this open relationship
thing now it sounds like you're having
serious marital issues yeah
i'm not really sure you'll be like [ __ ]
for this yeah it's been like [ __ ] for 10
years it's like
are these two in the same yeah they're
not relevant um
are you just trying to get some [ __ ] off
your chest yeah i'm only deep in that a
lot more now that you're saying out loud
because
when i read it i digest it differently
to when someone reads it to me yeah you
know yeah
because when you read obviously you know
it's easier it's easier than done
yeah of course but like yeah i'm not i
think we'll have to tackle each bit in
its own
as far as the open relationship goes
that was one million percent
always going to happen because when
you're a dude and you're in an open
relationship this is how [ __ ] goes
you win an open relationship you either
you like you're in a open relationship
you then have permission to go and [ __ ]
girls
so you go and try and meet a new girl
and you either have to lie
and say you're single and then lie for
the entire time that you're [ __ ] her
um and in a rope relationship
you don't want to go on dates so if you
meet a new girl you've got somehow
manage to [ __ ] this new girl without
taking her on dates
you have no interest in dates yeah
you're married happily married yeah you
just want some pum
yeah so now you've got now even pat and
a new girl
without taking her on any dates and just
smash her which is
physically impossible basically um
especially he's been married for ten
years he's getting on and he's getting
out of the game yeah he's been out of
the game you don't know how to partner
quickly like that
or you start moving to girls that you
already know
and convince to believe convince them to
believe that you are actually in an open
marriage now
so i'm an open relationship and i'm
trying to do a thing they're going to be
like
are you sure fam and they're probably
going to message your wife like
he is saying all kinds of [ __ ] is this
true and that's just
the whole
[Music]
so it's never going to work for him it
was never going to work for him
he just fantasized it the whole time he
thought brother i've got pump at home
i've got put him out on these streets
like it's easy and then i've got
everything i want to do like the snuggle
bugs
at home with the misses the dinners the
best friend chat all that at home
and when i want a nut i can just
basically pick and choose who i want bro
he didn't know
he didn't know it was going to pattern
out like this and now she's getting
pipe left right and center and he's not
about it at all because that's got
wretched yes
it's what happened to will smith no
basic thing yeah
they weren't an open relationship and
she was piping also yeah yeah exactly so
that was never going to work so it was
no surprise that he backed out at the
last minute
um are you the [ __ ] in my opinion
no of course not because you both agreed
that this is what you wanted to do yeah
and now he's realized it's not what he
wanted but it's too late
like you're not an [ __ ] for wanting
to continue to what you agreed to do in
the first place that's basic
as far as i think what do you think i
think she's not an [ __ ] but
within the same breath like you said we
need to tackle it individually because
you said
or she said rather that it was first of
all this open relationship thing
and then it moved on to him treating her
like [ __ ] for x amount of years
so you're definitely not the [ __ ]
for the first for the first thing i
don't think so either purely because
it was a mutual agreement you guys said
okay boom we're going to open up this
thing we both like sex and blah blah
blah
just because the hubby ain't getting the
panani doesn't mean you should be
getting the dick
yeah exactly that's something else
that's a completely different topic yeah
to worry about
and like you've rightly said it goes one
or two ways
he's never really going to get that much
pump but she's clearly going to get it
because men don't care like that
man will sling the dick okay if you're
married
any open relationship not open [ __ ] bro
if you're trying to [ __ ] he's going to
be down he's going to be down
so the treating him to him treating you
like
[ __ ] for x amount of years has nothing
to do with the fact
that or might be the reason as
to the spur of the me wanting to or her
wants to continue the european
relationship
so i feel like that's uh that's an
unfair advantage
yeah in us not really not really
advantage
but like there's another reason as to
why she wants to do it as opposed to the
initial conversation should we have an
open relationship
that's the thing as well and i think if
to add on to your point if that's
what this is really about if the actual
problems in your marriage and it's not
just about the sex because
an open relationship as far as i'm
concerned should just be about sex
it should just be getting sexual
fulfillment elsewhere because you are
in a committed happy relationship and
there's one thing that you want to
improve on
if your husband's treating you like [ __ ]
and you're looking
elsewhere then we're kind of not in the
realm of open relationship anymore
you're kind of in the realm of
yeah yeah yeah you just want someone
else yeah you want because you're gonna
be emotionally invested in someone else
yeah yeah because
you're like he's treating you nicer
you're gonna want something you're gonna
want him in the end so you're gonna
leave it
it's not the same thing yeah they're two
completely different things i think you
need to dissect about what it is you're
actually looking for yeah if you're
looking for strange pipe
and a good time then no you're not the
[ __ ] you're having a good time
like you said he's your best friend etc
etc all good
but if this is the the cure quote
unquote for your marital issues
then boy you are looking in the wrong
place
100 you need to sort that out in your
own house yeah yeah before you start
looking for pipe elsewhere yeah because
this is a completely different issue
um but yeah that's what we think anyway
i kind of like that one though because
it's different it's very yeah exactly it
was very different like the last one as
well it's very different it's not
the usual and because they're married as
well that's
that's different i don't think we had a
married one before that i can recall
not immediately that jumps to my mind no
but no
um no we don't think you're the answer
for what you don't yet we don't think
you'll also for the initial thing
but the second bit about him treating
you like [ __ ]
completely two different topics and i
think that's probably
the reason why obviously the reason why
you want to continue to open
relationships i think
the whole initial thing was irrelevant
she shouldn't have even told us this
first thing
she should have been like my man treats
me like [ __ ] we
previously agreed to open relationship
but i want to continue this because he
treats me like [ __ ] what do i do
yeah i need a break from him you want to
break
yeah yeah yeah he's crying every day no
wonder he's crying every day
because you you've you've emotionally
tapped out
you're not about to say you're not about
it anymore and he can clearly see that
and
there's nothing he can do for what he
did in the past you treated like [ __ ] in
the past he can't change that you know
but he's only i'm assuming he's only
realizing the mistakes he's made
hence the reason why he's trying a lot
harder now you know yeah you're
basically saying it's too little too
late
that's basically what you're saying so
this is marriage chat they're saying no
open relationship chat this is
we're not the real therapist you need to
get to my dog i think we can give you
the best advice we can but
you need to speak to someone else about
that one yeah because this is deeper
than
i think you even know you need sessions
yeah yeah yeah you guys need to invest
in some counseling
if you want to pay us yeah we'll try our
best
i've got no degree in that but i'll try
bruv i'll hear you man now
um hopefully that helps you yeah but i
hope that gets resolved for real because
that's um
that is tough marriage isn't um it's not
an easy it's not an easy right i'm an
easy task
10 years in as well kudos that's a long
last time
that's almost as long as i've known you
yeah bro that's a long time to be
married
cool well guys signing out thank you so
much
have a great week yeah and we'll see you
in the next one